hi everyone and thank you for joining us
today we're here to talk about critical
design considerations for rapid
diagnostic tests in a covered 19
pandemic
so we we're joined by a group of panel
guests so in no particular order we've
got brendan o'farrell the president and
co-founder of tcn diagnostics
we've got davon rolls who's the
president and ceo of sona nanotech
klaus hockleiner who's our technical
specialist at sativa and david wilson
who's the commercial director at avacta
the format of today's call is we're
going to have a discussion around three
points so understanding the different
technologies available
moving on to why a dual approach between
those different technologies is the best
approach and then spend some time around
the different design challenges that
people will face when developing natural
flow tests and what support exists to
help developers
so to start brendan would you like to
help explain the different technologies
available
sure thing thanks lee
um
so i guess the you know the methods for
for testing uh relatives to seroscope to
infection really break down
broadly i suppose into into molecular
versus immunoassay so molecular tests
we're looking for obviously the
molecular material of the virus you know
in the case of steroid b2 that's rna so
the primary method used is rt-pcr and
that starts by converting the viral rna
into dna and then amplifying it
using pcr to a level of which it can be
detected so several other isothermal
amplification methods obviously are
being
developed and implemented as well so the
main advantage of rtpcr in this context
is the relative speed of the assay and
the fact that it can be automated and
high throughput and it can be very
sensitive and specific if it's developed
correctly so
uh but obviously rtpcr has its
limitations as well uh the primary
sample used for detecting stars kobe 2
is a nasopharyngeal swab
and those are difficult to collect
effectively and they're really
uncomfortable for the patient
taking them also potentially exposes the
health care worker taking the sample to
infection which has pushed us in the
direction of a lot of thoughts around
self-sampling
other sample types like nasal swabs and
tongue swabs are being evaluated and
implemented but they obviously come with
their own challenges as well uh
particularly when it comes to the
performance of the assay
so traditional rt pcr requires a lot of
lab infrastructure a lot of equipment
trained users
and these tests are most commonly done
at scale in in central or hospital labs
as a result
so more recently we've seen some small
instruments developed that can be
deployed to more decentralized testing
environments and these have the
advantage of a lot more portability
but obviously they're complex
instruments for the most part still
requiring trained operators
and at least some infrastructure and
maintenance so it is also the primary
issue i suppose of access time to
delivery of results and scale
and turnaround time right now on
centralized rgptr assays
from sample to results is on the order
of multiple days uh even in the best of
circumstances
so processing of of cover 19 samples
also requires by containment labs
operated by highly trained technicians
obviously
and for more resource limited countries
with less access
to central laboratory resources and less
capacity
than the developed nations this kind of
central lab testing at the required
scale really isn't an option um so the
alternative approach is immunoassay and
with this format we're detecting the
presence of specific proteins in a
sample
that are indicative of current or
previous infection and these assays can
either be instrument based and run in a
central lab but they can be run at the
point of care as a rapid assay
the most ubiquitous format of rapid
assay being the lateral flow format of
course that most people are familiar
with in the context of pregnancy testing
or
hiv testing or strep throat testing at
the at the doctor's office but has been
applied as a very mature technology in
literally hundreds of applications over
the course of the last 30 years or so
so there are two primary applications of
of the immunoassay in the context of the
pandemic i suppose is antigen detection
and antibody detection
there's a lot of different use cases
around each type but in broad strokes
you know the antigen detection uh
indicates the presence of
viral proteins in the sample once again
typically the nasopharyngeal swab in the
current
embodiment and the presence of these
protein antigens like the spike protein
is indicative of infection with the
virus so
the value of the antigen testing uh
probably self evidence you know if a
swab taken from a patient test positive
they're infected and likely infectious
uh on the the serological assay or the
antibody detection assays these use
binding reagents to detect the presence
of antibodies directed against the
specific viral antigens
so typically we're looking at uh igg and
igm
although there's growing evidence that
iga has has utility in the context of
cobot
so stereological assays are useful
because a patient that's recovered from
covert 19 um
once the virus is cleared from the body
the viral rna is no longer available for
detection in the respiratory tract so
there's really pretty short window
during the acute stage of infection in
which cytoskeleb2 can be detected using
pcr or immunoassay for viral antigen
detection so while the pcr or antigen
detection by immunoassay works well for
diagnosis of ongoing infection it
doesn't give a clear indication
of whether a patient has been
infected historically and potentially
and i would put a lot of emphasis on the
word potentially
what their immune status might be i'm
sure we'll come back to that
uh but antibody tests have their
limitations too um though data is still
emerg emerging
it appears that the the antibody
response to covert 19 is slow compared
to a lot of other infections
and with limited data it appears that
the initial igm antibody response
doesn't peak until about nine days after
infection and the igg response
uh is several days after that
and to put this into perspective most
viruses would elicit a primary immune
response within about five days of
infection now because of this stars kobe
2 antibodies
are unlikely to make good uh markers of
acute coca 19 infection so you know as a
result the detection of antibody alone
for acute phase diagnosis is really
viable and and the topic of whether a
total antibody test is the ideal
specification rather than one that
differentiates igg and igm is being
pretty highly debated in places while
antibodies you know might not be
appropriate for acute phase diagnosis
they still show a lot of valuable
applications uh in the context of covert
19. so potentially the most valuable use
of wide-scale antibody testing is as a
public health tool you know indicating
levels of exposure to the virus there's
lots of talk about using these assays to
indicate immune status but the science
is still largely out on whether that's a
valuable use case for a lot of these
tests
but today i'm aware of at least 12
different identified use cases for
serology assets
a lot of which required somewhat
different assay specifications so how to
use these assays and develop them is
going to be a hot topic for some time to
come so hopefully that outlines the the
basic framework lots of details and
nuance in there to be debated and
discussed but uh i'll hand back at that
yeah no thanks brenda that's brilliant
so i guess you know from that
explanation close are you able to help
explain how
i guess we're using both of the
molecular and amino acid approach in the
real world to tackle this
well the point was the
molecular diagnostic test was that
um these were the first tests that have
been developed because people quickly
sequenced the virus are created primers
and were able to detect
the
virus in patient samples
as brandon already pointed out that's
something that needs to be done in a
centralized lab uh it's something where
you need an infrastructure train people
you have to ship the samples to the lab
and it takes ages before you get the
result back to the patient and that
means in that time yeah you either have
to guarantee the patient
uh or the patient will spread the virus
to other people
um
the development of
tests for antigens for viral antigens is
ongoing
so first test on the market was limited
sensitivity but the original idea is to
have a test that identifies
the patient
as positive let's say in a doctor's
office
um and is then confirmed by a molecular
diagnostic test in essential laboratory
so that would be a two-step approach
um and that should avoid um at least
false positives the risk is false
negatives and the tests that are
currently on the market the best one has
a sensitivity of eighty percent uh that
means of uh ten people that are really
real positives that you test you will
miss two
um and that means at the moment as a
stand-alone test uh it's not yet
feasible
and this is what people are working on
uh what makes your life an additional
misery is that um that there are four
endemic human coronaviruses that cause
10 to 15 percent
uh of human common colds
uh these viruses are all closer related
so you have a fair chance of
getting
positive signals that are from a
biological biologist's point of view
real positive signals
um and unfortunately you detect the
wrong virus
um things will get worse when we talk
about antibody tests
the first problem is that
in a typical study what you see is that
the first igms appear on day five of the
onset of symptoms
and then you have forty to fifty percent
of the patients uh developing the
antibodies um you will have igms in all
patients around day nine or ten
uh which makes that as brandon already
said a no goal for
finding acute phase diagnostics
and uh what is even more interesting is
that um antibodies against different
coronaviruses cross-react
uh this has been uh published for zazz
kobe one
um and uh antibodies against the endemic
human coronaviruses we know it for the
merc uh coronaviruses it's the same
story and it goes it goes in both
directions and there is absolutely no
reason to believe
uh that this will be by any means
different for saskov2
um and that means if you go for antibody
tests you have a very high chance to get
an awful lot of false positives that
means uh you will run into trouble with
your epidemiological statistics
at the end it means we need to develop
more accurate
tests for the antigen in order to
help diagnose our corbit 19
in under-resourced regions uh and even
in in what we call first world countries
in um in a near patient situation in a
doctor's office
um and then confirmed that by a pcr test
what i do not buy and to be honest is
the idea to have self-sampling
self-sampling regardless whether you use
another pharyngeal
samples or saliva samples
has a very good chance um to fail
due to our user errors
um and that makes them
very difficult
um as a as a screening test
and this is what we're looking for and
um that means i would always opt for a
test that
why the sampling is being done by a
trained person
which leads us back to the doctor's
office
so that's for the approach that is
uh that is currently being used so do an
immological antigen test first
um and then do a confirmatory test uh
for the positive tested people
um we have to develop antigen tests that
have a sensitivity that's much better
than 95 percent
uh else it will not be useful for a
screening test
and the antibody test that we are
talking about will not involve a
two-step approach
uh but they have a fair chance to give
you false positives due to crossroad
activities was the endemic human
coronavirus antibodies
um and
um again
this needs
to have a very high sensitivity and
specificity in order to be useful as a
screening tool to talk about
um
immunity and the population whatever
that means
and
nobody knows how long it will last
the problem is we know from all other
coronaviruses it doesn't last forever
and again there is no reason to believe
that this will be the case
that this will not be the case for this
new coronavirus
okay thank you
yeah we will need to test for a very
long period of time
yeah
okay now if i get close i think that uh
you said quite a good picture of how
complicated this is to get something
with the required level of sensitivity
and accuracy that we need
which i know you touched on a few
different areas there you know such as
sample collection and other pieces but
maybe david you can help um
start the conversation around some of
the design considerations and some of
the challenges that um
typically you've encountered during the
development
um yes so out of acta we we've been
focused on the development of a uh
antigen test
on a lateral flow platform and recently
announced our collaboration with sativa
to develop that particular test
the aim is is to develop a test that can
be easily deployed in a community
primary care
and
a uh
you know a consumer
setting
we believe the lateral flow format is is
the really the only format that we're
aware of that will enable the mass
testing
or mass population screening that's
going to be required in order to get
society back to
normal whatever normal will be
and there is a lot of demand for this
type of testing
outside the traditional healthcare
settings
one of the biggest opportunities is to
enable workforce testing for example
to get workers back into
into companies um uh to get you know
sporting events
back uh concerts uh
public transport
um so there's a there's there's a huge
demand so we've been focused on the
development of a test which will enable
that to happen um so that
that's good that requires a what we
think is a lateral flow uh format and uh
saliva
as a sample as opposed to the
nasopharyngeal swabs
so um some of the the challenges well
one of them is time um
you know typically these tests take you
know many months uh you know 18 months
18 to 24 months to develop
we don't have the luxury of that
at the moment
and so uh all companies i know that are
developing these and other coffee 19
tests are trying to
do it in a
way that's different from how it's
normally done in order to accelerate the
time to market and and clearly that
introduces um you know a a somewhat risk
um
but uh you know we can't we don't have
the luxury of 18 to 24 months
to to get these these products out
so that's um that's one uh very big
challenge
also the
access to
clinical samples
you know they are in
high demand and short supply
um increasingly so as the as the
pandemic
starts to um
disappear
although i agree with klaus's earlier
comments that they need for testing and
the demand for testing
is not going to go away for a very long
time you know we anticipate that there
will be a need for testing you know in
in very significant numbers
for at least another 12 months
so time is a challenge um
and
the
develop a test that can be deployed in
these settings is also
one of the biggest challenges for a
diagnostic test developer
because of the the need to develop a
test that can be used
easily by
a consumer for example for a self-test
so that's a challenge it's also a
challenge from the regulatory approval
process
um you know typically the regulatory
approval for these tests
um and the clinical validation study
needs are are significant so again
the
uh authorities the fda for example
the mhra in the uk um are looking at
ways to
provide accelerated approval processes
for these tests so we can enable them to
get to market otherwise again
they won't be coming to market in time
to enable us to fight this this pandemic
so there are a lot of challenges
associated with the fact that we're
trying to get something to market um
much much more quickly than than than we
would traditionally do as a as a
diagnostic
product manufacturing company and and to
be honest our are you know probably more
comfortable
um
doing with the the more standard
timelines um
but
um you know we these these tools are
absolutely required without them
uh
it's going to be much more difficult for
us to um to get society back back to
normal
so there's uh
and then on top of the all of this
there's supply chain issues i mean i'm
outlining lots of problems um but
they're they're really just to introduce
maybe topics of conversation for the
rest of the the the webinar um because
of the the demand for for these for
these tests the supply is under a lot of
strain and that's the supply not just
the tests themselves but all the
components
and raw materials and that's an issue
which needs to be addressed because the
supply chain needs to be ramped up
um again
in a in a time scale which it's never
been done before
so yeah it's it's uh
it's just an outline of some of the the
major the major
hurdles and and challenges that we're
we're facing at the moment to get these
products to market
okay thanks david darwin to say anything
you'd like to elaborate upon what uh
david's added or anything you didn't
produce from your side well
yeah thankfully um
well as david outlined you know i think
uh you can
everybody listening to this can probably
get a sense of the enormous challenge
that uh anybody that's developing one of
these tests is up against uh for sure um
and and it is it does come down to time
constraints um you know that's a major
thing
um you know david outlined you know all
the problems that we're seeing um
you know so i'm not gonna kind of dwell
on those you know
they'll be discussed as we go through
this presentation i think one of the one
of the major things that um you know
sonar
has come up against with regards to
challenges um in terms of our biggest
hurdle is probably that um you know
access to some of those materials um you
know it being everything from
test component materials all the way
through you know to some of the specific
biological materials that you need to
get uh to be utilized um you know
similarly back the test um so this test
has been based around the ice
antigen-based tests um you know we
initially were focusing on the
nasopharyngeal swab uh type systems
um but uh our our platform and our
process is easily adaptable to other
matrices including uh you know saliva as
well uh but uh our first person after
his priority really is to um you know
kind of see a critical path to
developing a test
uh
utilizing um a nasopharyngeal swab
and so it's alongside all the other kind
of constraints that david's
kind of outlined around you know time
regulatory clinical pathway
um access to materials etc uh you know
i think we echo one another and um you
know and we've spoken um you know
offline around these things many times
um one of the other major things uh
probably at least going to be a
challenge which is we're certainly a
topic of discussion that david just
touched on is the infrastructure around
um you know the development of rapid
tests now typically
you know lateral flow tests
hundreds and hundreds of millions of
these tests um you know produced every
year across a plethora of different
disease states and for many other use
case scenarios but they typically
there's probably
maybe a handful or two of core material
suppliers
for things like membranes and pads and
antibodies even
but then also machinery to produce these
tests you know there's unless you're
unless you have a significant production
set up in-house which obviously some of
the major players do
but everybody else doesn't then they
utilize um you know cmos that are out
there contract manufacturing
organizations and again there's
typically a handful of those um that you
know obviously we're in discussions with
multiple uh groups around that and um
you know one of those challenges is
about around
uh
beyond the test development process
itself uh you then typically would go
through a tech transfer process
uh which again normally uh we talk about
normal versus expedited time frames that
our process is normally a six month
process in itself um and we're asking
those cmos to pretty much rip up the
rule book um you know
but but still make sure that they're
doing to those quality systems to make
sure products that are transferred are
done so correctly and then produced at
the scale of manufacture that is
expected because um you know
as we know the the mass screening that's
required here uh that's uh expected uh
to ramp up production from even even
from a few million tests to hundreds of
millions of tests which is what we all
anticipate that's needed and you know
it's a huge task on
not just us as test developers
but also all the manufacturing
organizations as well and those typical
those manufacturing organizations are
typically serviced by again a handful of
companies that you know produce the
manufactured equipment um so it's a you
know as a diagnostic india as a whole
everybody that's in this tight network
i've all recognized the challenges we've
all kind of um everybody's come together
uh very very quickly you know what we're
once seen as competitors are now
certainly collaborators
um
everybody's working hard together to
kind of uh you know
allow each other to bring those tests to
market because everybody can see the
need uh you know for that
so supposedly just to pick up a little
on the on the topic of development
challenges you know the
dcn diagnostics is a contract developer
of lateral flow assays this is what we
that's what we do for 11 is what we've
done for for several decades now and
um
you know so we're we're used to dealing
with the with the with the typical
challenges right that
everybody in the industry is aware of
you know starting from the concepts of
designing really usable tests for point
of care application which covers
everything from getting the right sample
to getting the test to run correctly to
making sure it can be interpreted
correctly digitally or by eye
to the analytical challenges of just
making the system work selecting the
right reagents getting the right
materials ensure that
everything as as as as darren and david
said what goes through the correct
process and goes through it correctly
ultimately ending up in a properly
validated product that can then be
scaled and manufactured right
um
so all of those challenges still exist
here but let's say we're you know
obviously we're trying to compress this
timeline
and and we're doing it based on a on a
real risk benefit analysis right so
there's there is risk to this kind of
acceleration
and the reason we go through that usual
process of developments is to end up
with a really robust reproducible
product that can be scaled right
and as darren points out that that
scaling and that manufacturing requires
a very very specific and quite limited
skill set
um so one thing that in this whole
process that can't be clawed back you
know obviously the development happens
on a continuum so we can draw the lines
anywhere in the process to say
we've reached a point where we're happy
to
release this product to market we've
reached a point where we're happy to
submit this to
a regulatory authority under an
emergency youth or authorization or
whatever the case may be
but what we can't claw back in that
process is time right so we are drawing
a line in that development process at a
point where we haven't by definition
under any circumstances demonstrated
that our products are highly
reproducible and highly scalable at the
level at which we're going to have to
manufacture them so there's inherent
risk in that process
so what we have to do as development
organizations and manufacturing
organizations is try to pull back as
much of that risk as we can
through you know the still the proper
application of development methodologies
and understanding that even after we
have released these products to market
in this specific instance uh development
continues right this is this is not a
there's not a defined line here that
says this product is gone
um it's the exact opposite in fact you
know from every level of this process
the fact that the target product
profiles are still shifting both for
antigen and for antibodies so we
actually don't really have a great idea
of what the final product has to be
we're making some very well educated
guesses
um
but that's that's going to change so the
target product profile is going to
change the performance requirements are
going to change our understanding of the
process is going to change our
experience with these processes is going
to change over time so this is going to
be very much an evolutionary process um
and and one of the things when we're
talking about supply chain that that
that we see as i i guess one of the
bigger risks certainly we all understand
the reagent supply issues
we understand the material supply issues
we understand the you know the
manufacturing equipment side of things
one of the biggest gaps we see in the
market and
is is knowledge and it's in its
education you know a lot a lot of
companies have been forced into a
position where they're having to scale
manufacturing processes really quickly
uh they're having to do so with with
people who may not have the experience
level that that we'd like to see you
know in these processes and again
there's a there's a risk benefit being
done here we need these products but but
i certainly wouldn't
skip over the the question of the
knowledge gap that's in this market
right now we need we need more trained
people we need more experienced people
and that's unfortunately not something
that's going to happen quickly but it's
something that we need to work on too
no i think it's very good and one of the
things
so one of the things that works in a
while i know that um
you touched it very briefly earlier was
about uh the importance of time to
market sorry the time to test
and i'm getting a quick result on these
which
you know it's critical that um we have a
instant result where the current
bottleneck is taking several days
sometimes for results so to help expand
on that piece that you mentioned earlier
brendan
sorry you actually broke up on me there
just a little bit so the questions
yeah when we were talking about the
different technologies and you
introduced arts um you've seen that
lateral flow the importance of this is
you know getting a quick result
and i guess you know
just some of the challenges around that
i guess in what you're saying about the
less reproducibility and that you're
able to go for at the moment
well you know the the time to results
obviously in the context of the testing
that we're doing time to result is
critical right so
um
one of the benefits of lateral flow
technology you know as a platform is
that allows us to take a sample do the
test on the spot and have a result
within minutes
um now we can couple that obviously with
reading technologies as well whether
they're you know within the cassette
whether they're external readers
um
and do instantaneous data gathering
databasing we can have all of that data
available
in real time as well so there's obvious
benefits to that in the context
particularly of antigen testing where
we're trying to get to a decision as to
whether somebody has an active infection
really quickly
get them into quarantine
take whatever uh measures need to be
taken to ensure their health and safety
and that of the people around them
um
and so so having that instantaneous or
virtually instantaneous results is a
really really huge benefit um
now in the context of you know mass
population screening uh you know
particularly in the us you know the us
has
growing uh capacity for
centralized laboratory testing where we
can take those samples turnaround times
will improve but we're still talking
about probably days from sample
collection
to delivery of that result so in the
context of antigen testing that still
introduces a gap where there's where
there's significant risk um now in the
context of antibody testing where we
have so many potential use cases that
people are looking at and some of them
do require that instantaneous results
right so
some of the back to work testing or you
know testing of healthcare providers or
whatever the case may be we need that
results right and and this
that both from a serology and an antigen
perspective i think the lateral flow
platform
provides probably the only available
solution
um
so it's uh you know it's it's
it's really ideally suited to this uh in
in many many ways
okay thank you to the technology that
that that's correct the problem my
problem is that we need specificities
and sensitivities on an extremely large
scale that is definitely unprecedented
uh simply due to the fact that's a
massive screening and this has never
been done before
uh in all electric flow tests that we
have on the market you'll have patients
that show the symptoms um and yeah if
you want to test
what we want to do now as we would like
to test people that have no symptoms we
have the slightest idea whether they
haven't they have or had an infection
and we need a test that gives us an
actual result um
on
answers to these questions
and uh that's a completely different
piece and
the second problem is this this virus is
a new virus and that means it's a
rapidly moving target
uh currently i'm
seeing about 50 papers at least per week
published on on pre-print service so you
can't read them all
and but by the knowledge that that is
gathered and the surprises that uh that
are appearing as as really astounding
and we as as test developers or material
developers or reagent developers have to
try to take place with it and that
that's a real challenge
and from an algorithmic perspective you
know one of the biggest differences here
is that we're talking about utilizing
a serology test in a way that it's not
normally used right so serology tests
are usually reflexed to some kind of an
orthogonal message for come from our
method for confirmation right depending
on
you know the the the endemicity of the
environment they're used in so
uh in this case we may not have that
safety net so it's different
yeah it's different there's absolutely
no safety now
yeah i think the the sensitivity issue
clause that you brought up and we've had
numerous conversations about this over
the past two weeks
um as you say i think it's uh it's a
major challenge uh you know for for
anybody developing a test trying to get
that sensitivity level down um you know
i think we've discussed whether you need
to get viral load readings down to you
know the ten to the two ten to the three
level um you know just to get a sense of
the limit of detection of these tests
and if not lower um you know to detect
you know bible loads in patients um
because
i say that differentiation between
symptomatic or presymptomatic patients
and asymptomatic patients um is a mass
difference you know when it comes to
screening because
i think uh you know present even
pre-symptomatic patients um you know
it's hard for them to get a test in many
countries um you know that certainly
don't have
huge capacity for centralized lab
testing um you know so i think screening
tests like uh you know the ones that
we're trying to that we're all trying to
develop here and whether it be antigen
or antibody based um you know certainly
have the role to play in it and as we've
alluded to before that risk benefit you
know kind of trade-off is the main key
thing but again coming back to the some
of those technical challenges the
sensitivity is going to be the one the
major issue and there is that
specificity issue around that
cross-reactivity interference um you
know whether the existing kind of
thought-based uh
viruses that are floating around in the
environment so
um again beyond you know
supply chain organizational issues
there's actual technical issues that
simply need to be overcome uh you know
by everybody as well
and they chose their own challenges but
i think uh you know the world and
certainly our space that's full of smart
scientists and we're all working hard to
overcome those issues and i think we're
you know i'm sure together we'll all be
able to uh you know do so
uh yeah that's right i think specificity
is something that
many people overlook at that point uh
let's assume you have uh five percent of
of uh the population or with an active
infection
um
that may or may not show symptoms so
that that's the big problem
um and you have a specificity of 95
which means that uh 100 negative
patients 5 will come up with a false
positive
the outcome of that is even if you have
100 sensitivity that um it's it's a
little bit more complicated
mathematically but uh what you would
have is that from all of these positive
tested people
uh 50 are false positives
um and
that that's that's a problem because
everybody uh would say oh come on what
what is this for a test because when you
run the confirmatories on a pcr test for
example uh 50 of these patients um turn
out to be negative but you have
guaranteed them you have uh
probably uh look for contact persons you
have put a guarantee in other contact
persons um
and
you'll panic an awful lot of people and
at the end people will say that the
tests are the rapid tests nuts
um and that's also something that needs
to be considered
yeah i'm just building on that uh class
obviously when you're looking at trying
to get you know the best test will be
high sensitivity high specificity but
often it's a trade-off isn't it when
you're trying to
get you know to get high sensitivity
often you know you have to give
something on specificity and vice versa
i think for the antigen test
um
the
the bias will be you know obviously
sensitivity and negative predictive
value
um you know it's not ideal having too
many false positives but i think it's
even worse
um having too many false negatives
um at least with the false positives
there may be a a a way to introduce a
confirmatory test for those
but the false negatives you would never
know
um and
to have someone walking around thinking
that they're they're not infected when
they are um
uh could be uh would be a much much more
uh difficult problem so i think if if
you if you have to go one way or the
other then for the antigen test the bias
should probably be towards
uh sensitivity
yeah ideally
higher levels but
yeah def definitely yes so in an
infectious disease test regardless what
we are talking about it doesn't
necessarily have to be a zaskel v2
uh
19. um in an infectious disease that's
what you're looking for as as the best
possible sensitivity because you do not
want to see any false negatives you will
necessarily 100 sensitivity since there
will always be clinical outliers that
you simply will never find regardless
how good you do your your clinical
validation
um but the difference we have here is in
just opposite to any other
uh infectious disease that's that that
is
on the market is we want to do a
screening test and that makes
specificity
a bigger hurdle than than usual
let's assume you look for a uh you do a
hepatitis b test and you have reasons to
do the hepatitis b test and if you have
some if you have a 95
specificity
um the few false positives that you have
well
the number will be much lower than the
real positives that you have in the
screening tests a 95
our specificity can easily bring you to
more false positives than right
positives and and that
that makes that that will give you
problems
um not necessarily on the market but you
will run a large number of
confirmatory tests that come back
negative and uh i said you will you will
create
a lot of trouble with the patients uh
was there was their environment their
personal environment their work
environment
so you may shut down complete factories
due to faults for positive tests and
that's the worst case
and that's something we need to deal
with
yeah
okay i
you know we've got about five minutes
left and i think that i need to jump in
because you could probably spend another
half hour or so you know probably longer
it's still going round with
the team on the call so maybe we can you
know cover some more in the questions
that come up from uh the audience but
maybe as a way of you know closing the
call and summarizing if we can go around
each person maybe in alphabetical order
so someone brendan this may be any
advice you could give to people looking
to develop these tests or what supports
available that you could help advise
them through to
well i mean there is a there's an
enormous amount of support available you
know so um
particularly you know the the us system
is the one we know best you know there's
a lot of support in the u.s system right
now uh coming from nih coming from bardo
coming from a variety of different areas
both from a funding from a networking
and from a technical perspective um
you know within the industry itself um
you know there's again there's a there's
a network of core providers that have
historically existed within the lateral
flow space uh companies like ourselves
that are on this this call
and i think we we've historically all
had a
a
a culture of of
both promoting the best possible
practices within the latter flow
industry
and assisting companies coming into the
industry so there is quite a bit of
technical resource available from
the materials providers from the reagent
providers from companies like ourselves
that are contract developers and
educators and trainers and contract
manufacturers
so there is quite a bit of support
already out there inherent in the
industry everybody is everybody is
strapped from a bandwidth perspective
you know everybody is busy right now
but at the same time we all recognize
that the importance of this
and i think as an industry one of the
one of the most heartening parts of this
for from my my own perspective has has
been watching the reaction to this from
the
from the service and materials and
equipment side of the business from the
people who really facilitate the the
development and manufacture of these
um the industry has really come together
in in quite an incredible way so i think
anybody anybody who touches really any
one of the core suppliers in the
industry is going to get network very
quickly into the other aspects of what
they need so
um you know we're we're here to support
both the
the companies that are that are newer to
the industry as well as you know the
more mature
developers and manufacturers or that are
you know just under pressure with this
whole thing to have to
develop products while validating them
while standing up new manufacturing
lines and new facilities while training
new people
um you know we're all here to to to help
as best we can
okay thank you
and darren
uh
yeah um just uh like
uh brendan's comments really around how
that network has all come together it's
uh really encouraging it's really
heartwarming um you know i've been part
of it for you know
15 years in various guys's uh through
contract manufacturing organizations to
now kind of heading up a test
development group ourselves um you know
and i found that that network that i
kind of got in touch with over the years
and built um you know
certainly kind of come to fruition in
helping us deliver and you know this
test to market as quickly as we've been
able to
um you know
my advice to anybody kind of stepping
into this is um a initially look at
what's already in the market um you know
to determine whether you know is there
is there an opportunity here for me to
compete in that market with that test um
albeit that you know we're going to be
testing a covered you know
sales call to
a long long time um you know you want to
make sure that you're in a position uh
you know just to make sure your business
is competing there
and so once you've identified which area
you want to kind of work into
get in contact with as many people as
you can within this network be it um
somebody like brendan at dcn to help
with that test development
uh with people like klaus um you know
and yourself uh you know around those
membrane suppliers and we'll then
certainly put you in touch with all the
other key suppliers for materials you
know uh reach out to people like myself
and david who supply some of some of the
reagents into it into the network as
well um yeah because you're going to
need that you're going to need that
support um you know as well as the the
end manufacturers
and even regulatory and quality support
as well and one of the first things we
did when we started doing this
uh was reach out to the fda
and get that contact in there understand
what they needed uh as part of this and
what they were gonna do and and they
held their hands up and they were like
we don't really know yet tell you what
let's work together and try and figure
this out
um you know which was great
in one way and it helped us and you'll
kind of steer our path in that critical
path but certainly use the network this
day um it's a it's a fantastic and
heartwarming network that's accessible
to everybody and they'll they'll embrace
everybody with open arms
thank you darren it's uh really
insightful david anything to add from
your side
well i mean i think uh darren and
brendan have pretty much covered it but
um i would just like to add that uh that
sort of network and collaborative effort
um extends to the you know to the
different uh players different companies
in the industry itself i you know i've
been in the industry for many years as
as we all have and i've i've never
experienced such a collaborative effort
and putting aside some of some of the
normal competitive uh issues um there's
a collective effort to get these
products to market um
as quickly as we can so that's that's
heartening i also think the uh uh what
by going through this now uh the
industry is going to be
more pandemic ready next time because
there will be a next time and there may
be a next time for this current pandemic
um but there will be another pandemic
and i think what we've gone through in
terms of
getting ourselves
prepared to develop products which will
help tackle this pandemic will put us in
a very good place um for the the next
time it happens we'll be able to respond
much more quickly and i think for the
industry as a whole um
this has been uh it's an opportunity for
the industry to showcase what we can do
and what value our products actually
have and because that i think has been
somewhat under the radar uh from for for
many many years and um
so those are i think those are those are
many of the positives so someone coming
into this i think would um
would find a
an awful lot of support for all the
different
uh sectors that um brendan and uh and
darren have
have said including
companies that they would typically
see as their competitors
okay excellent thank you david close
anything briefly on your side because
we're about to reach a q a
so some some famous last words yeah i i
could bore you with with another comment
on networking and i will definitely do
that so so
what all of us
have told you is yes networking is key
here
uh we talk about an unprecedented
situation about a pandemic
that will
nobody will able to deal with that alone
so the advice is get out of your ivory
tower don't try to reinvent the wheel on
your own
and and talk to people talk to to reach
supplies to material suppliers
and uh work
in in a network and that's the only
chance we have
uh to get
uh this pandemic under control to have
to have tests develop
uh that really do the job that we want
them to do
um and to be prepared for
yeah um another pandemic um or the
reappearance of uh sasko v2 because
uh
if there's one thing that is sure it's
not over yet
and uh this virus will stay with us so
uh there there's enough work to do
okay excellent
and um i guess that brings us up to our
q a deadline so thank you everybody else
i think it's been you know excellent
really appreciate your insights and your
input and i'm sure the audience and
everyone joining this session will
you know echo that comment as well so
thank you very much and i think we'll
engine hand over to our q a